you
hi everyone it's Jerry this is a very
brief review of the 2013 World Chess
Championship match between reigning
champion Vishy Anand and Challenger
Magnus Carlsen and for the most part
we'll simply show the moves of each of
these games with some comments along the
way this was a best of 12 round match
played in Chennai India in November of
2013 and it was a race to six and a half
points if any one of these games piques
your interest feel free to check out the
link I'll provide to the right of the
board and there you can see more
thorough commentary so this first game
had Carlsen with the white pieces
electing the ready opening and well
similar to what we can find maybe in a
boxing match a lot of feeling out of an
opponent in this one that's the early
phase of this match what essentially
went on and at the end of this game one
we had a perpetual attack against that
White Queen
this one here ending peacefully after 16
moves in about an hour and a half's
worth of play game 2 was interesting
such that we saw the Carroll Khan
defense by Carlsen not too common at top
level of play we go down a main line and
at the end of this one we have opposite
sides castling which is usually an
indication that we'll be attacking one
another's king but soon enough what we
see is that there are simply too many
pieces being exchanged and the most
powerful one the Queen comes off there
is some threat being generated here
against the black side but it is simply
dodged with the black King bouncing back
and forth avoiding Bishop takes h6 and
this here also ending peacefully after
25 moves and about an hour and five
minutes worth of play this scheme here
turned out to be the shortest of the
entire match game 3 without a doubt of
the first three was the most exciting we
once again see the ready but with c4
inserted we have an imbalance with
regard to the pawn structure white
having a two-to-one majority in the
center but it was black who was decide
who was pressing in this game for a
great portion of the game and after the
match it was Carlsen who said that
he sensed that Anant was he that he
sensed Anand was also nervous in this
one and well we end up having Carlson's
Queen getting kicked around and why
exactly was Anand nervous I'm not sure
why he he thought that it might have
been maybe around this point where there
was an opportunity to take on b2 but she
chose maybe a more reserved option of
Bishop d4 at the end of this we end up
seeing opposite colored Bishop ending
and not long off from here I think
around this point
Anand offered a draw but it was declined
and well the result is not going to
change it does in fact turn out to be a
draw but only after all mating material
has been exchanged off the board and
this one this position ended up getting
stripped down to opposite colored
bishops like so of course this one here
is also going to be a draw so three
games so far three draws game four was a
very very tense one we saw Anand
choosing the right Lopes we have Carlson
electing the Berlin defense and the
Queen's come off the board this here was
a game which was a very long fight and
great amount of accuracy was played on
Whiteside very brave play on the white
side to do something very reminiscent to
1972 match Fischer Spassky grabbing that
rook pawn it seems like the bishop is
trapped but it's able to just sneak away
and return home and although black is up
a pond is getting now rocked back and
what we see is the whole chessboard
being made use of in this one King side
Queen side as well as the center a lot
of pressure being placed on black for
having grabbed that pawn and now the
White King getting very active white
here being down to pawns getting one of
them back super active King at the end
of this white at this point is now
looking for a single rook endgame
which will be a lot easier to hold
wanting it to be where it's just two
ponds and two ponds versus one on one
side of the board there is some accuracy
however needed on whites part there is a
little trick that black is throwing in
at this moment rookie six white is sure
to dodge that and well at the end of it
we do as white managed to get a pair of
rooks off the board and just having a
single pond advantage is not going to be
enough to convert this one into a win
four games in four draws fifth game
however is where we saw first blood I
guess you could say the the semi Slav
elected by Carlson the Marshall gambit
which really isn't a gambit due to
knight c6 on move six Bishop d2 on that
move six would have been a true gambit
but not the case here and in this one
the Queen's come off not without having
some structural defect on both sides
white aims at c6 which is a sensitive
point at the end of it we have a nice
move here with b7 making sure the Queen
side structure on the blacks end will be
a little bit weakened white is the side
who's really trying to press in this one
looking to get to the seventh rank
looking to now improve on the King
position and black did well to really
get that rook on h8 finally working some
threats are now being generated against
white b3 has pressure King c3 has was a
nice timely move in order for B 2 to be
played at the end of this one however
although it is stripped down to a rook
position and white having only one pawn
Plus that pawn Plus that white has is a
very significant advantage because it
means that there are now two past pawns
to past rook pawns the apon gets tracked
down but black has quickly reminded that
there is also a past H pawn on move 58
after H Ford is Anand who resigns and
this here is the first decisive game of
the match game 6
was well what a non ended up describing
a very heavy blow we once again see Roy
Lopez and this was a very very quiet
game one that had I believe most people
thinking it would turn out to being a
draw but Carlson continued to fight on
in this one and soon enough we see all
minor pieces exchanged in this one and
we're working now with just rooks and
queens some structural defect on the
white side but it's never it shouldn't
really be enough to turn it into
advantage but what we end up having is a
material plus on Carlsen side soon
enough okay a lot of dancing at this
point soon enough we end up having just
the rooks on the board right here Anand
gives up upon in order to have a very
active rook h5 is thrown in giving up
another pawn to shatter the structure
and now slowly but surely white well
black is going to now improve the King
position black gives up not only the
b-pawn but also the sea Pond and this is
this is a big moment coming up here in
the match after the roof gives a check
King seif king f4 means that it's now
the sea pond will be given up light has
connected past ponds but black has a
very very dangerous pond in that of the
F pond which simply at this point can
not be stopped and soon enough we end up
having after rook g1 Anand resigning for
now the second time and Carlsen going up
by two points and again Anand later
describing this one as a very heavy blow
in the match Game seven well not having
the white pieces we once again have the
Roy Lopes but now with some twist
grabbing on c6
it's turned out to be a very positional
battle and no imbalance with regard to
the minor pieces but rather just the
pawn structure some activity eventually
ensues on the h-file with it now being
peeled open that
is going to be an indication more pieces
will be exchanged the rooks in
particular and sure enough we have both
sets of rooks coming off and this one at
the end of it we end up having the
Queen's and the Knights and not really
much to make of this position similar to
games 1 & 2 we end up having a little
back-and-forth with the Knights and the
Queen here and this one here ending as a
draw so not at this point is certainly
running out of time
game 8 being the next one here and well
this is a very quick game
I believe Carlson spent about 20 seconds
on average per move we see the Roy Lopez
and this is a very tame line no
structural imbalance just getting the
minor pieces out and we really get to
see highlighted this position stripped
to a very simplified position the kings
and pawns alone no minor pieces no
queens no rooks
soon enough bishops are now off and with
this now sequence of moves mass
exchanges at the end of it with the four
King and pawn endgame alone soon enough
we end up having the Kings side and the
Queen side being locked up no progress
to be made we now turn to game 9 running
out of time at this point is a non
needing to certainly score win one of
his last games here potentially playing
with the white pieces and this was a
giant giant battle we had a big race in
this one the nimzo-indian the kamacho
variation with f3 and white looking to
prep this efore advance white is
successful in doing that this Knight is
a little bit of a nuisance on White's
part being camped out on the Queen side
and now here comes a giant avalanche of
the white pawns another interesting
thing to note in this game is that we
had the the biggest think of the match
after b3 and on spent about 45 minutes
on Queen to f4 moved 23 and while this
night is now jumping all the way back in
order to defend against mate white is
going for it with rook to F
or allowing a second queen to be placed
on the board promotion on b1 but with
tonight to f1 that turned out to be a
very serious blunder and after the reply
Queen to e1 Anand resigned this one as
well
Carlsen now up three full points in this
match and certainly a very difficult
road ahead nearly impossible tasks to
win the next three to force a playoff
game ten would turn out to be the last
game of the match Carlsen at this point
having six points anon having three we
have a Sicilian Carlsen needing only a
drop in order to secure the world
championship and well very strong grip
is placed over d5 in this opening no
imbalance with regard to minor pieces as
soon as that LightSquared Bishop is
exchanged and there's just the two
breaks b5 and d5 to watch out for
looking for a very simple position this
game I thought might have been heading
towards well at the beginning of it I
thought we could be seeing a very quick
draw but always had a much bigger fight
as soon as there's for as long as there
are Knights still on the board we end up
having all my major pieces being
exchanged for as long as all Knights or
both Knights are still on the board
there's still a lot of calculation
needed so there's a nice King position
and well now this Knight is getting
involved here trying to go after the
black pawns a great thing here on
Carlson's part almost a 1/2 hour was
spent a night g8 why is that the case
well because at the end of it you need
to see that you have to give up your
knight and you need to know that you can
track down the a and B pawns for black
and just in time be the one who gets a
Queen first of course black gets a queen
as well but at the end of it there's not
really going to be much to make from
this position and at the end of it after
Queen c7 Queen b6 without the Queen's on
the board this game here turns out to be
a draw and with that Magnus Carlsen
becomes the 16th world chess champion
scoring now six and a half points to
three and a half points
you